and now I would like to introduce you to
charissa little who is the director of
professional education at the Stanford
center for professional development
Carissa oversees the center's portfolio
of professional education offerings and
has worked with Stanford University for
over nine years Thank You Sandra
today I have two esteemed colleagues
with me first is Professor bill Burnett
he's a consulting faculty member in the
Department of Mechanical Engineering and
the design group here at Stanford
University he's also the executive
director of the Stanford design program
after years of drawing cars and
airplanes under his grandmother's sewing
machine bill went off to the University
and discovered much to his surprise that
there were people in the world who did
this kind of thing every day without the
sewing machine and they were called
designers 30 years five companies and a
couple of thousand students later bill
is still drawing and building things
teaching others how to do the same and
quietly enjoying the fact that no one
has discovered that it's he's having too
much fun at Stanford bill manages the
undergraduate and graduate programs in
design at Stanford
both joint programs between mechanical
engineering and art in addition to his
duties at Stanford he serves as a board
member of DCM the product design
consultancy dalton energy and
alternative energy company focused on
developing biomass gasification energy
systems for small-scale municipalities
and advises several internet startup
companies on design strategy we also
have with us today and Eve energy he's
an associate professor in mechanical
engineering and the design group and
it's director of the Stanford design /
officially trained is an architect and
he holds graduate degrees in
architecture mechanical engineering and
design in his early career in India he
worked in the fields of architecture
structural engineering and built Adobe
housing for the rural poor after coming
to the u.s. his interest in the
confluence between digital and physical
experiences took him to Xerox PARC where
he worked on ambient media and physical
computing he also worked for I do as a
designer and a design strategist
creating novel experiences and crafting
futures for high technology
he's the founder for the design for
change lab where he addresses the issues
of sustainability technology features
and the dynamics of rapid change
currently he's working with faculty from
behavioral sciences social economics
systems analysis management science and
engineering and art to generate new
platforms for design thinking in
addition to his research and technology
and design theory he was a technology
artist for the new San Jose
International Airport he is happiest in
the presence of sharp minds sharp
cutting tools wood dust cutting oil and
the smell of smolder and with that I
would like to turn the floor over to
Professor Phil Burnett
good morning thanks for joining us
something looks like we have quite a few
people in attendance again if you have
any questions please join ask the
questions over the web chat and one of
us will get an answer back to you so
Jeff Immelt the CEO of General Electric
made a pretty important statement a
couple years ago in his annual meeting
he said the global economic crisis is
fundamentally reset the way companies do
business and even capitalism itself at
Stanford we work with lots and lots of
industrial affiliates we call them
companies to come on campus to work with
us in the design group to learn about
our thinking on innovation our research
and how you create you know new
strategies for companies but I think the
emphasis on innovation as a strategic
tool and design as the way of creating
innovation has really sharpened in the
last few years primarily because of the
increasing competition and the fact that
the big global downturn 2009 2008 really
forced organizations to look for new
ways to create organic growth through
design and so what we've we find
ourselves in the situation we find
ourselves okay coming up with asking
these questions excuse me we were just
fiddling with slides here if you find
you find yourself with
fewer resources now than ever before I
certainly I certainly know I do even at
the University here we're constantly
downsizing and re resourcing the
projects that we're already doing but at
the same time are you being challenged
to implement more projects in spite of
the fact that you have fewer resources
almost all the companies that we talked
to our in this situation and then
globally are your markets under attack
from competitors who have either lower
cost structures or you know or even give
you a product away for free some of this
comes from the globalization of the
economies around the world the world
becoming flatter and flatter and some of
this comes from you know new and
innovative companies here in Silicon
Valley that change business models by
giving problem look at look at Google
giving away spreadsheets and word
processing and everything else for free
simply for the right to pop an ad into
your browser so you know these are these
are huge shifts in marketplaces which
are creating real dilemmas for
management teams and then overall if
you're addressing these kinds of
problems through some sort of a strategy
of innovation in your organization are
you happy with the process are you
getting what you think you should get
out of innovation and the investment
you're making there are companies that
we work with in telecommunications in
the pharmaceutical industries that are
spending billions and billions of
dollars in their R&D labs but are they
really getting the bang for the buck
that they're looking for we really think
of the answers to these questions are
critical and if you're like most of the
senior managers surveyed half of you are
going to say you're really dissatisfied
with your return on innovation the
Boston Consulting Group does this survey
every year of senior managers in the
Fortune 1000 companies and year after
year 54 55 56 percent of the senior
managers say I'm making a significant
investment in innovation practices in my
company and I really do not understand
what the return on that investment is if
you're a manager in an organization and
you are
trying to manage a process you can
neither measure the output from nor
understand the process you're in real
trouble I think that's why in a lot of
cases when the economics of a market get
difficult
the first thing management teams cut is
R&D or innovation or new product
development they can't they don't
understand that they don't understand
how to make it more predictable
predictable and they can't figure out
how to measure it so the first thing
that goes is the thing you can't measure
and we really understand you know this
um this dilemma because on the one hand
you have to have innovation you have to
have new product development or new
services that you that your company
brings to the market you have to respond
to competitive threats when your
competitors innovate and at the same
time just throwing money into the black
hole of R&D seems like a poor management
strategy so these problems trying to
innovate with uncertain boundary
conditions trying to come up with new
ideas when you don't know what the
competitive landscape is really going to
be essentially the problem was trying to
predict the future then these problems
are classified as wicked problems
problems that are poorly bounded and
some are suggesting that this thing we
call design thinking is as a potential
answer to using innovation as a
strategic weapon Harvard Business Review
is written about it Roger Martin is the
Dean at the Rotman School of Management
at the University of Toronto wrote a
great book called the design of business
where he talked specifically about using
design design thinking as a methodology
of business management tim brown the CEO
of IDEO one of the top product
development products strategy companies
in the world wrote a book called change
by design which talks you know because
lots and lots of case studies of using
design as a strategic weapon in
organizations and they panic the
president of jump associates a sort of a
design research firm but a book called
wired to care on the same subject
Roger Tim
have all spoken here at Stanford we're
very very much aligned with the research
that they're doing and the epideictic is
one of our one of our senior lecturers
so these are you know these are folks
that are proposing this methodology as a
business strategy rather than simply as
a design strategy and Bruce Nussbaum the
writer used to be of BusinessWeek's now
a professor at the new school of crap
has talked about this extensively in the
press this notion of a creative economy
so there are there's a lot of there's a
lot of movement in the direction of
design thinking what we're going to try
to do today is talk a little bit about
what the frameworks of design thinking
are and why they might be useful in a
strategic role rather than a tactical or
just design role I'm David Kelley who's
one of our senior professors also the
founder of our new design Institute the
d.school
which is our Graduate Institute where
we're teaching design thinking to people
from the School of Business School of
Medicine the School of Education lots
and lots of different touchpoints around
the university he's also the founder of
I do you know it says the next
generation of innovators and leaders
really need to be great design thinkers
and we probably argued great design
strategists and one of the frameworks
for use is quite simple and it's this
this diagram just below the quote you
know it's it lots of people have toget
processes you do concept first and then
you do development and then you have you
know big tollgate meeting and you have
another meeting another meeting this
this process that we've outlined here
empathize define id8 prototype test
really if we were to draw that correctly
that would be a circle of these
pentagrams and the test would lead back
to empathize it's not a tollgate process
it's simply as Tim Brown describes in
his article in the Harvard Business
Review it's a series of spaces you
occupy or a series of mindsets that
you're mindful of empathize is the
process of using ethnography and need
finding to understand the latent needs
that your users have define is creating
a point of view around those
NEADS ID 8 is creating generating
through brainstorming and other ideation
and creativity techniques many many many
solutions before you zoom into several
that you prototype and test with users
then go back from the knowledge you
gained from that to the empathy stage so
I mean that's one very simple process
diagram again not a tollgate diagram but
more a series of spaces that the team
occupies we use multidisciplinary teams
a radical collaboration in the design
thinking process where almost everyone
in the organization is involved so I
mean you know what I'd like to do is
turn it over to my colleague Danny
Banerjee for him to talk a lot a little
more in depth about a number of these of
these steps and the frameworks that we
applied to each one but what I want to
leave you with is the notion that when
you're dealing with a classical business
problem a problem that you can reduce to
alternatives because you have the data
to do so you can decide whether a is
more efficient than B or a is a larger
market share than B and you can make a
decision you can decide your way forward
I'll so I'm in a band and I live in the
engineering school when you use and we
have an engineering problem a problem
where you can isolate the variables
reduce the dependent and independent
variables to a series of equations and
solve for the correct answer then you
can you know engineer your way forward
or you can you know calculate your way
forward and the kinds of problems that
we're talking about that are best
addressed by design thinking you don't
have enough data to decide an a B
decision and you can't reduce the
problem to a well bounded set of
equations it's a classic wicked problem
so we say you can't think your way
forward or decide your way forward you
have to build your way forward you build
through design I'll now turn it over to
my colleague banging advantage and you
can talk a little bit about the
frameworks we use to decide what do you
build thank you very much bill
what has happened at Stanford over the
last 15 or 20 years is in our quarter of
Stanford we paid a tremendous amount of
attention to this whole thing of how do
you create transformation through design
and I'm just going to advance the slide
ok and and what we have is what we've
come upon is an entire rubric that we
call the Stanford design methodology and
it allows us to do a few things it first
of all allows us to look at problem
solving in a very very different way in
a very creative way and an leverages the
creativity that everybody has but in
extremely structured ways but before we
go on to problem solving because we have
you know we in in the past so many
different fields have come up with very
efficient problem-solving methods the
bigger problem is to figure out what the
problem is in the first place the bigger
task at hand and we've beat our rubric
and our methodology really lends itself
to a very creative framing of the
problem because that is actually the
larger part of of really making a
transformation that is meaningful and
and because a lot of our business
systems have relied so heavily on
capturing value it immediately puts us
in in this domain where it's called the
red ocean where all the sharks are are
going after the same food the waters red
with blood and everybody's trying to
capture the same value our processes in
contrast is very much about value
creation
what is how can one as an organization
and as individuals within a team the red
want creativity in very very subsets in
a structured ways so as to create value
that is very incisive that is very
tightly coupled with an eye and
understanding of what the need spaces so
I'm going to advance the slide and and
go on to this if you if you seen the
slide you see
a Venn diagram and and this explains a
very high-level view of where we play
this is what this shows is that
innovation as we define it is these very
much of the Nexus of business sources
and and business viability our
technological feasibility but what is
what it is really driven by is a genuine
identification of need of human needs so
a lot of our processes especially in the
framework that bill outlined you saw
that the first stage was actually
empathize and that is something that we
time and again in working with industry
we found that that going in back into
the field and really unpacking what the
new answers of the needs are is is
actually gives you the ceding functions
for extremely radical innovations but
it's not just individual needs
what is extremely important is to cast
itself cause this innovation in the
framework of very large forces the
sociological forces the cultural forces
and the economic and environmental
issues that this issue is costing so one
looks beyond the boundary conditions of
one's own domain and and gets around the
risk of in that you see a lot which is
organization seeing the world in terms
of its own offerings and then all your
locked him to do is making incremental
changes rather than radical radical ways
of creating new values so in you know if
you were to look you know fast oven and
say okay so what does design thinking
give you at the end of the deal it gives
you it gives you very very innovative
solution then innovation is one way of
defining innovation is a marked
deviation from the norm in terms of in
terms of the value uncreate if we were
to use the normal processes you get
something on the normative curve and if
you're using innovation you're using
creativity to deviate away from the norm
in creating something with this
proportionate value but what you can get
at is you can get at completely new
experiences that that the world has not
yet seem but which will the culture will
wrap itself around one can create few
visions of the future for one's own
organization one can create extremely
incisive and and clever strategies and
the roadmap step still out of that and
create an entire strategy for once an
innovation one can creat use this is to
change the organization and the way the
organization's functions and and take
the organization motor the part of being
innovative and and those spoke to the
sudden need that we have the the even
greater need that we have in today's
world about organizations being much
more agile and and innovative and that
brings us to the need for cognitive
shifts very often one can be very very
innovative within the framework of what
we are doing
but often it what it takes is a shifting
of the framework itself
one in terms of the offerings that one
is going after one cannot just look it
of an offering as a solution but as a
platform that will create a whole that
will serve the larger brand or the it
will serve the entire innovation
strategy so so what is it that is
engendering at the largest scale that's
those are questions that can be that can
be addressed through design thinking
what's fun is also after in is
completely new behaviors in one's market
and among one's uses if you can come up
with with offerings that change change
behavior are not only have you created
value in terms of in terms of a new
behavior that that people are are having
in order for that is better for
themselves you've also made created
market conditions where the behavior the
supporting your offerings this whole
thing of incidents making incremental
changes leapfrogging beyond the current
realm and anticipating the future and
and getting getting way past and
creating blue ocean strategies where one
lands in an area where one has created
value
such a novel way that for them for the
moment there are no competitors there is
another issue that that is beginning to
surface and in our minds is is is going
to become a very relevant issue for all
organization and that is one a
sustainability so we are paying a lot of
attention to how you build the
sustainability into the equation no
matter what you do um the other thing
that we are very cognizant of and being
Stanford we are you know at a very high
level we're about creating leaders we're
about about training people to go out
there and make very massive impact and
to repay a lot of attention to lead to
to what constitutes leadership and and
creating the new rules as as the
landscape changes and what we find is
that there is a new form of leadership
that is emerging and that form of
leadership actually has is very
different in mark ly different from from
what leadership used to be in the SDS
this is very much about forming forming
visions that are very creative and
influencing one's organizations to be
very innovative and creating value and
creating new markets that's what
leadership is about and and that map's
very very well to to the processes that
we are speaking about and and and we
speak to a lot of leaders and and we get
this is not just our point of view but
we are triangulating with with having
been been in conversation with some of
the top leaders in the world so so how
does one go about doing this it's you
know and dimension different classes of
challenges and he mentioned a wicked
problem here is a truth table which is
essentially four quadrants and and it
asks a very simple question do you know
what the outcome you want to have is and
do you know what the process for that is
so there are two questions and just it's
a truth table and depending on whether
you know what you outcome is and you
Auto processes you land in four
different quadrants now if you happen to
be in a sector where you know exactly
what the outcome is and you also have a
process for it then it falls in the
category for paint-by-numbers kind of a
kind of problem and that refers to the
paint-by-numbers refers to the
children's books where you join the
number dots and you just you just join
it to the next dot and in a picture of a
clown or a picture of a lion emerges and
that is in if you happen to have the
privilege of being in an organization
which feels safe in operating in last
way every dollar spent on innovation is
a waste of that dollar you do not need
innovation in this one but typically
most organizations even in extremely
stable environments are can outperform
the market and up from the competition
by using innovative techniques and then
if you're no longer in that data realm
so you could be in in the quest realm
where you know what the outcome is but
you have absolutely no idea what the
process is now that is one where if you
don't know what the processes are you
could be looking for a long time before
you find the outcome the the the process
could could be very elusive and and that
is that's a process we call that's a
realm of challenges with that we call
the quest now most problems of the type
that are emerging especially at the
strategic level are it happened to fall
in the fog region where the outcome is
unknown and the prop and and the process
is also not very clear it's all you know
is that there is a large challenge that
one needs to get to a solution which is
very different from what one is doing
there must be a really clever approach
or an idea or a clever framing out there
but it isn't quite clear as to how to
get the entire organization of the team
or just as an individual how do you get
there and that's called a
project and what we do is we don't start
office with the notion that we know what
the outcome is what we do is to turn the
fog into a movie kind of a project a
movie project refers to and then the way
the reason why it's called a movie
project is because the movie industry
has a process down to as to how to make
a movie and sometimes there are as many
as 500 and 600 people that get engaged
in creating a two-hour experience and
and there's a lot of money involved and
a lot of choreography involved but the
movies could be very different from each
other a movie could be a an action movie
or a romance or or a thriller or
what-have-you and and but the process is
very very well well understood and
that's how we approach fog problems that
are that are wicked problems that are
ill-defined problems and what we do is
we rely on a process that we rely on to
that that uh that unpacks the issues and
simultaneously frames the problem side
as we work on the solution side and as
you're working on the solution side it
feeds back into under for redefining the
problem side such that the most optimal
outcomes and the most robust outcomes
the merge outfit you know very very
robust but also very economical way a
lot of these processes have come out of
the need to manage resources very
tightly while trying to again get at
very disproportionate outcomes so a lot
of our processes speak to that I think I
skipped two slides now this is another
view of the sequence that that bill
mentioned and it's it's a framework it's
on on the x-axis you have time and your
attendant I'm you have a challenge and
you're going to move in time and you
want a certain kind of outcome and but
the the y-axis out here see
is to REMS one of them is the concrete
realm and the very very tactile and an
understandable realm and the the other
extent is an abstract realm and our
processes we find that you have in in
navigating the process well it is really
important not just to stay in the
concrete realm in march in time and go
from defining a problem and coming up
with innovative concepts in in the
future what we find is that it's
extremely useful to generate the kind of
insights that lie in people's lives and
in reality and in understanding what's
happening out there but go off slowly by
these processes of synthesis and frame
working into an abstract realm and there
are all these processes that are linked
to it and what you arrive at is a very
defined crystallized mile high view of
what's happening and it allows for the
use of very different cognitive
processes than are typically at play in
in say engineering we use very heavy use
we make very heavy users of synthesis
which is a little different from
analysis analysis is the act of breaking
down a problem into smaller and smaller
bits and gaining a lot of confidence
from having broken it down and gaining a
lot of confidence from how defensible
that little piece of information is and
synthesis is a little different where
you're piecing together different
different components each of those
components might be extremely innocuous
and and and simple but the way you piece
it together might might result in a very
magical configuration and so that's a
very different kind of cognitive style
and we have processes that that that
drive that till you get it a very
crystallized and very insightful view of
what the landscape is and what the
framework is and that allows you to do
some abstract operations and make some
strategic cause a
- what what is it that you're going to
do what is the space in which you can
operate what are the high level
objectives that you want to achieve and
then there you embark on on a set of
processes that get you to a very wide
selection of concepts in a very rapid
time scale and what we believe in at
Stanford is that the the act of building
is not just an active of expressing what
you've already thought of but it it's
actually a cognitive mode in itself as
you prototype your solution you come to
a much deeper understanding of the
integrated space in which one is playing
and it gets to much more much much more
integrated solutions and then so then as
you come up with concepts you come back
down into the concrete realm and
essentially what one is done is a very
tight knitting of the opportunity space
and what can be done in reality so so
again like what the you know just as a
strategic tool Design Thinking allows er
allows for a very very unique set of
outcomes first of all it it allows for a
very strategic framing of the problem
space a lot of time or rather a lot of
effort and intensity in inertia in a
short time frame is dedicated towards
framing the problem side really well
it is these processes are very useful
when the problems are a huge overlap of
very many different domains and
functions and you're trying to satisfy
many conditions simultaneously and also
where the nature of the problem is not
clear and there are many feedback loops
and and these design thinking processes
are very useful in creating guiding
visions and and in the in visions that
are very very easily communicated
through the organization and serve as as
as the the guiding star that that all
the other actions polarize along
and more most importantly these
processes are very easily learnt this is
this it's not rocket science every all
of us have a lot of latent creativity
and these processes are very easily
learnt and practiced and so it's easy to
embark on a part whether there's a
culture of innovation that that is
brought into an organization and these
processes when used in combination with
other proven techniques that are already
in place just leverages the
organization's positioning of a whole
lot with that I will pass it on back to
Karissa and let her explain the rest
thank you so much Vani I just want to
remind everyone that at the end of my
section and we'll be answering some
questions for the presenters live so
just feel free to be submitting those
while I speak at the Stanford center for
professional development we're part of
the School of Engineering and we've been
delivering education to industry for
over 40 years and so we have reasonable
experience in creating educational
programs to address the career-long
learning needs of professionals managers
and executives and Industry we at the
Stanford center for professional
development are pleased to be offering
the Innovation Master Series in
partnership with faculty like Bill and
banning for three days senior faculty
will lead you through hands-on workshops
where you will experience the
problem-solving tools and problem
finding frameworks that lead to
innovation and strategic leadership
pioneered by the Design Group and the
d.school at Stanford so here you can see
sort of a listing of who we think can
benefit from the program we designed the
program for managers business leaders
and decision-makers faced with the
daunting task of retooling and
revitalizing their enterprises so I
encourage you to kind of take a look at
this and see if you are one of these
folks and
and working through some of the
challenges that bill and vani mentioned
earlier we created this program because
we've been hearing for quite some time
how organizations struggle to make
innovation a routine within their within
their organizations and today's business
environment companies continue to be
challenged to implement more projects
with fewer resources you heard that from
Bill earlier today here you can see some
of the key takeaways that can help you
navigate tomorrow's business challenges
to impact the long-term success of your
company and to create that return on
innovation you heard about from Bill
truly one of the most unique aspects of
the program is that you will get the
opportunity opportunity to engage with
the who's who line up a faculty from the
Stanford design group and the D school
who really pioneered design thinking to
solve today's wicked problems and I you
know one of the things we heard about
last year was that the faculty are so
engaged in this in this program and and
are there throughout and that's quite
quite a unique aspect you don't
typically get that many you know famous
faculty all in one place at the same
time so now we'd like to take a moment
to conduct a poll that we truly
appreciate your feedback on if you could
let us know what your level of interest
in the innovation master's series is
design thinking in the art of innovation
we really appreciate your feedback and
we'll leave this open for just a few
moments
okay thank you so much for your feedback
and so now I'd like to move on to the
question and answer portion of our
presentation number of great questions
came in while I was speaking and so the
first question how does one measure the
return on innovation well I mean this is
Bill Burnett let me see if I can take a
crack at that you're obviously going to
measure in the same way you measure
other things although you have to be
careful that in you know in measuring
the phenomenon you don't kill it you
know ideas need some time new ideas
innovative ideas often are look kind of
different to the organization they
should they seem threatening in some
cases to the existing business maybe
cannibalizing products or services that
you already offer and so the natural
tendency of organizations is to shut
down things that are unusual so there
has to be a part of the process which
protects you know the early forms of
innovation but our our methodology
doesn't rely on having like one big idea
and then you know and then it works or
it doesn't
our methodology relies on the tight
coupling of a prototyping processes
which really is a process of asking
questions it's not a process of building
things that you think will work it's a
process of X asking questions with users
and engaging in you know commerce a
co-creation process so one you have to
have a part of the process which is
protected from measurement because
you'll you'll you'll not be able to get
enough information to make good choices
and you're most likely will damage or
kill the most innovative ideas that have
the highest potential
they'll be threatening to other parts of
the organization but once you've got you
know things kind of out of that
incubation stage you want to measure
innovation the same way you measure all
other processes you're looking for a
return on investment highly innovative
solutions that have no markets are
really if not much interests highly
innovative solutions that address a very
niche or narrow market function
typically not useful as at all and so
you know the standard
measures of market size return on
invested dollar and overall kind of
looking at the long-term prospects of an
innovation all of which are standard
business processes but again what we're
talking about here isn't just hey I came
up with a new copy tub to replace our
old coffee cup we're talking about
coming up with new platforms for
innovation I would I'll give you an
example I was seven years at Apple
Computer not during this period I was
there prior to the invention of the iPod
but I think it's it's an overused
example but it's also often
misunderstood when the iPod first came
out when I was first introduced by Steve
Jobs Apple stock dropped for three
successive quarters and the world
thought it was a joke you don't remember
this time but there was a period of time
where people said you're kidding me a
300 dollar mp3 player 300th entry to the
market of the other mp3 players or sub
100 bucks most of them are you know some
$50 an apple in its arrogance introduces
a $300 hard drive based mp3 player
nobody understood it as because as a
standalone product it would in fact have
been a massive failure what they didn't
see was that it was a platform and they
didn't see it until three quarters later
Apple introduced you know the iTunes
Store and deals with all the five major
record companies that's what created the
innovation not the device not the
individual object it was stepping back
and understanding that you had to create
a new platform and you had to create a
new behavior as Manning spoke about in
the past you have an mp3 player could
only hold maybe 50 songs so you had to
pick which 50 songs you wanted to go
jogging with or which 50 songs you
wanted to take on the airplane you know
ride to Grandma's house Apple changed
the paradigm you could now have
thousands and thousands of song you
could have all of your songs on on your
eye on your mp3 player and moreover you
had an ecosystem for refreshing those
songs easily comfortably legally it just
opened up a whole new possibility that
you never had to edit your library so
in the early days I'm sure there were
people who said gee sure we should be
developing you know a $300 hard drive
based mp3 player this has got nothing to
do with what everyone else is doing
luckily inside Apple I dislike that are
protected they're protected particularly
because that strong design leadership
from the top but you but once you had
launched the iTunes Store and the whole
ecosystem and platform had been revealed
you would measure the strategic
advantage of that by looking at how it
shifted the conversation from where an
operating system company to where a
media company you would also look at the
basic return on an investment the
profitability of selling that piece of
hardware given the number of downloads
per device was extraordinary and you
know buy any other business metric he's
considered a homerun so you can use
traditional metrics at the tail end of
the process was the product and the
platform were launched but when you're
talking about creating innovations with
new platforms you have to incubate you
have to protect the babies while they're
still kind of growing up you don't judge
them yet until probably they hit you
know their teenage years that takes a
lot of management focus it takes a lot
of management commitment and that's
typically led from the top rather than
from the bottom great Thank You Belle so
I think that's that next question is for
Banny
does the Design Thinking Nexus suggests
that the thinker's must come from or be
a member in the social cultural or
economic environment from which the
problem arises the answer's no the
processes actually allow you to enter a
universe where which might on day one be
completely unknown to you and unfamiliar
to you but but there's a way in which
with fairly economic means and we use we
make very heavy use of of techniques
that we have stolen from the world of of
cultural anthropology of going in
quiring in these areas that might be
variant very unfamiliar but coming back
with the kind of insights that that
those drives will drive the strategies
are there's a way in which you you go
and inquire in a very open-ended manner
rather than stepping through through
questionnaires if this is you're looking
for the driving forces and the
underlying forces that are that are
causing the causing the the behavior
then latent needs that people are not
able to express but once they see the
solution they'll they'll think that
meaning they had wanted that all along
but they don't know how to express it
and the process is in Los Angeles in
that so no you do not need some molarity
often an innovator and a design thinker
is put in a position where they have to
go to a country they know nothing about
and in very little time figure out what
is meant what is a really good offering
so that that particular context great
thank you
it will take two more questions live and
then the rest of the questions will
answer at the end of the session so the
next question is how do you actually
teach this to engineers at the skill
level and not just at the theoretical
level oh boy that's um that's a ton of
fun actually that's what we spend most
of our time doing you know the
undergraduate program that I'm
responsible for is an engineering
program people come in and thinking they
want to be a mechanical engineer or a
lectric 'el engineer and then and then
they get very excited about design but
as you might imagine my very very smart
very very bright undergraduates here at
Stanford didn't get 800s on their
creativity SAT because there isn't one
they didn't get eight hundreds on there
you know innovation SAT because there
isn't one but they did probably get
eight hundreds on their math so they're
pretty linear thinkers when we start
it's a process first of engaging what we
call visual thinking because your brain
is a massive visual processor and you
are aware of you can verbalize only a
very small amount of the information you
synthesize but you can you can
synthesize information visually you do
it very rapidly so
part of the process is just teaching
them to reconnect with their visual
thinking we do this through a great
class called introduction to visual
thinking any 101 or there's lots of
drawing and building and prototyping and
visualizing ideas once you've got a good
path of sort of visualizing ideas we
connect it with this notion of need
finding the empathy side of the project
you can generate lots of ideas but
they're not connected to human need they
aren't very useful so then that's an
interesting other challenge to teach
engineers typically less empathic less
social IQ sort of folks how to truly go
out and interview in an unbiased way as
Danny was talking about using the
techniques of ethnography cultural
anthropology to observe with a
beginner's mind to really emphasize with
people who are struggling to solve a
problem either a physical problem a
technical problem a social problem
whatever so we have a deep dive class on
ethnography and empathy and we and we
teach them lots and lots of tools you
know and engineers or anyone likes to
have you know when I'm trying to when
I'm trying to turn a screw and you screw
to everyone I'm trying to crank a bolt I
need a wrench if I pick up the wrong
tool I'm going to get a you know I'm
going to get the I'm going to get a bad
result so we have a series of tools we
have a series of processes and
techniques wrap it all in the design
thinking methodology it's actually
pretty fun and even with the graduate
students just sort of watch the
transformation to take an MBA who is
very you know very structured kind of
thinking very powerful kind of business
thinker which is wonderful stuff and
we're not in any way saying that Design
Thinking replaces business thinking or
engineering processes not at all it's
just another another powerful tool in
your belt particularly for non non well
bounded nonlinear wicked problems but
it's fun to watch an MBA suddenly become
creatively confident again I mean really
in some ways I think maybe I'm not
teaching people anything they don't know
you were all while we creative when you
were in then kindergarten and first
grade and somewhere along the process
our educational system you know over
educated your left brain and under
educated your right brain if you want to
put it in
simple terms and all we're doing is
rewriting the connection between the two
and beefing up that muscle in the right
brain of visual nonlinear intuitive and
creative thinking and it's fun to watch
people transform as they go through this
these classes great thank you so our
last question that will that will do
live I know there's a number of
additional questions but we'll handle
those online once we've completed the
webinar today so does the concept of
moving from fog to movie challenge mean
that there is a universal process that
applies to all innovation challenges at
a high level going from a fog where
where the problem of the challenge is
unclear to a point where it does become
clear and one can make some strategic
calls
there are there might be very many
different processes out there in the
world but but we do have a very very
strong process to it and it lends itself
to an enormous diversity of challenges
you can use that process to to look at
something very technical it could be how
do you deposit a micron or a microliter
or a Pico liter volume of ink to go
through a certain space and and and it's
in in a print technology or you can use
the same kind of process with with you
know in the hands of someone who
understands the process you also mold
the process to the nature of the problem
the press not a it's not a
paint-by-numbers kind of a process but
the same general process would lend
itself to a very different kind of
challenge for example if you were a
mining company and you wanted to to not
cause civil wars that's a very different
kind of a problem but the same approach
would apply so the the process is
extremely extremely
awful and it's also very versatile great
thank you so much light I really want to
thank our presenters today for
facilitating a fantastic webinar I like
to make you aware that this is a part of
a three-part series and we have another
webinar happening on February 22nd and a
third on March 30th related to the
innovation master series so we encourage
you to visit our website SCPD dot
stanford.edu to check those out in
addition we have a February 16th webinar
occurring on a slightly different topic
on global product design similar and
related but not not exactly a part of
this series so thank you so much and
with that I'm going to turn it over to
Sonja who has a few closing
announcements thank you for
participating in today's webinar there
are still a number of questions in the
gray and we will continue to answer them
via I am we plan to make this
presentation available and we will
distribute the PDF of the slides along
with on-demand version in a follow-up
email thank you again for joining us